pitchblack okay Chronicles of Riddick
hmm
now just regular Riddick Riddick stars
Vin Diesel as the title character and
this is sort of a back-to-basics film
because the second film went way way out
of where it should have been that's all
I'll say about that film but pitch black
was a pretty entertaining movie that had
some good science-fiction elements to it
but didn't feel really expensive and it
was definitely a breakout role for Vin
Diesel who's very good as his character
and he's good again in this movie as
well this film starts out and Riddick is
stranded on this planet you don't really
know why he is there and for the first
act of this movie it's really just him
trying to survive against the wild
eventually he runs into this other group
of people and they have to sort of
figure out a way to survive against this
mounting force of otherworldly creatures
who are on this planet now I wasn't
really looking forward to this movie
civilly because the last one wasn't very
entertaining at all I didn't really
think this one looked terribly great but
I gotta say I was really surprised
Riddick is actually a pretty
entertaining movie
Vin Diesel is really good in this role
it's definitely a role that's good for
him he's the kind of character that
doesn't say much and wait does say
something it's important and he likes to
make those badass quippy lines and smile
a lot and talk a lot like this because
I'm Vin Diesel and this is how I say
everything because I'm but I like him in
this movie and I like him in general as
an actor he seems like a cool guy and
he's pretty good as Riddick and believe
it or not this movie actually kind of
surprised me I didn't mind watching this
movie at all the first act this movie
where it was just Riddick trying to
survive on this planet against all of
these bloodthirsty predators I kind of
loved it I kind of wish the entire film
was that way it was sort of like the
last half hour of predator with Arnold
Schwarzenegger where he was just trying
to survive in the wild and there were
all these things and the elements and of
course the predator creature against him
the first half hour of Riddick was like
that and I really wish the rest of the
film had a similar tone but once he did
run into this group of soldiers it all
started to make sense and you got a
taste of why certain things happened and
I get that and it's fine I don't really
think it derailed the film I just think
it possibly would have been a more
entertaining film if the entire film was
just Riddick against the elements but
really the last two acts of the movie is
Riddick against the elements still is
just more people involved and
so they cut away more from Riddick he
became sort of this shadow that could
just strike out and then back into the
shadows again and I enjoyed that aspect
of the film but I did want to see a
little more of him for that second act
and a few of the characters in that army
were a little okay they're just sort of
quirky people that don't really need to
be there but then some of them were
pretty awesome like Katee Sackhoff was
pretty badass as this chick who's in
this army who doesn't take anything from
anybody and she was pretty good in the
role a few the characters do feel a
little bit cardboard cut-out
ish little cookie cutter ish to me this
is actually like a late-night sci-fi
movie that's actually pretty good you
might pop it in a blue air with your
friends and enjoy it and that's kind of
where Riddick has a lot of charm to it
it's a fun sci-fi movie that although
the CGI could have been a little bit
better it just feels like this is a
movie that where they're really trying
to do everything they can with what they
have and I really like the fact that
they really tried to take the character
of Riddick back to basics a little bit
and make the kind of Riddick movie that
Riddick fans were really wanting to see
there's a corny element involving this
puppy that was like okay and but yes I
understand that later in the film it
meant something but it I don't know it
just felt a little cheesy to me it's a
good-looking sci-fi movie the suspense
is actually pretty good
Vin Diesel as good as the character
Katee Sackhoff is pretty badass in the
movie as well it's definitely rated R
also which is a plus I'm sure for fans
and for that reason I'm going to give
Riddick a B I think that's an enjoyable
sci fi movie and I'm surprised by it
honestly it's a good start to the fall
season so guys what are your opinion on
pitch black and Chronicles of Riddick
and have you seen Riddick yet and what
are your thoughts on the trilogy I guess
it's a trilogy now and no I haven't seen
the anime version not yet in case you
were curious guys thanks as always for
watching I appreciate it and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes
[Music]